thank you Mr Numbers a major development
in the case of the Teen who ran away
from her Muslim parents remember this
story after converting to Christianity a
judge has ordered 17-year-old Rifka
Barry to return to Ohio now where she'll
be staying with a foster family Robert
Spencer is the founder of jihad
watch.org he worked with rifka's lawyer
and attended several of the hearings in
the case he's joining us from as you can
see Boston Massachusetts good morning to
you Robert good morning okay so with
this case on Tuesday the judge down in
Florida said I got no jurisdiction over
this case I'm going to go ahead and send
her back to Ohio and she'll be parked in
foster care but interestingly enough it
doesn't end there because he said the
real problem is with the immigration
status explain that well it appears that
Muhammad Bari rifka's father is not in
the country legally and he has not
turned over the immigration documents
that would establish that he is in the
country legally after repeated requests
from Judge Dawson in Florida and
repeated Promises by his lawyer shyan
alahi and so if he does not turn over
these immigration documents Dawson says
he's not going to allow Ripka to return
to Ohio so how does that work then
Robert because uh it's kind of an
interesting catch here if the
documentation is not produced then she
technically stays in Florida ostensibly
till she turns 18 and then it's a moot
point yes well that would be the best
case scenario at the same time this also
could be setting us up for the worst
case scenario in that it could lead to
if it is definitively established that
the that the bares are not in the
country legally they could end up being
deported Rifka could be deported as well
and then in Sri Lanka she could be as
she herself has said she could be killed
or institutionalized there because one
of a portion of her religion believes
that if you leave the her previous
religion if you leave this Faith uh you
can be killed yeah that's rooted in
Islam and in my book The Complete
Infidel Guide to the Quran I explain how
apostasy law is rooted in Islam in all
the sects and schools of Islamic law
Muhammad the prophet of Islam said if
anybody changes his religion kill him
and so there's quite a lot of people
quite a few Muslims I'm sure who would
like to see RI gabari dead and she's
much more vulnerable in Sri Lanka
obviously than she is here sure what did
you make of that report that came out
down in Florida about a month ago Robert
that that basically said that they
didn't fear that she was in danger to go
back to Ohio some people have said well
that really wasn't a clear report what
do you think it was a drastically flawed
report in so many ways one of the
weirdest things about it was that the
Council on American Islamic relations
which is a group that is an unindicted
co-conspirator in a homas funding case
and a group that's had many of its
officials arrested and convicted on
terror charges you know them they were
actually present when the Florida
Department of Law Enforcement
interviewed Muhammad Bari and his wife
now why on Earth what by what possible
justification could they have been there
and that tainted the whole report
because then they come out and they say
lo and behold we didn't find any
evidence that these people are that RKA
was in any danger from these people it
just doesn't add up it's quite a caseing
we're keeping an eye on it uh Robert
Spencer joining us from Boston he's got
a brand new book out he just mentioned
it a moment ago it is called the
complete infidels Guide to the Grand if
you're interested check it out
everywhere all right Robert thank you